[Music]
we start this NewsHour with breaking
news from Ukraine at least five cities
including its capital Kiev have been hit
by as many as 60 missiles launched by
Russia people in parts of Kiev are being
urged to take shelter after the city was
shaken by three blasts Ukrainian
officials say Russia's military has
targeted critical facilities in high
kiviri and zapparisha deaths are being
reported in regions including donipro
and luhansk
of Rory challenge is a Lie For Us in
Kevin can you just run us through where
some of these strikes have been and just
how significant the damage uh has been
as well
it's been another tense and wearsome day
in the campaign that Russia is launching
against civilian life in Ukraine another
day where people had to run to the air
raid shelters or look to the skies as
cruise missiles whistles over their
heads at least 60 uh were launched by
Russia now air defense had significant
success in shooting many of those down
but
air defense is not infallible
particularly when there are so many
missiles launched so here's the damage
as we understand it so far uh khakive a
big city completely without power that
we know of uh in Creve Central City uh
two people killed five wounded when a
residential building was hit there
Odessa in the South there are power
shortages here in Kiev uh the capital as
you can see the low cloud cover meant
that when I was looking around earlier
tried to spot see the the trails of air
defense or plumes of smoke on the
horizon of successful strikes I couldn't
all I could hear was the boom boom boom
reverberating around the city as they
try to shoot the missiles down quite
Eerie I have to say now we know that
there were some successful strikes there
are power issues in parts of the capital
the Metro System was shut down so so
that people could use those stations as
bomb shelters and the mayor of Italy
Klitschko has said that there are severe
water running water disruptions around
the city but they're trying to get that
back up and running as quickly as
possible and that's going to be the
mission for the next few days or so get
those systems running again get the
backup generators going get the
Transformers going uh try to show to
Russia that this is essentially a
country that is not being beaten that
it's unbreakable okay Rory challenge for
us and Kiev thank you